vice president Mike Pence says he's now
willing to testify to a D.C grand jury
about Trump's attempts to overturn the
2020 election it's all part of the
special counsel's investigation into the
events of January 6th you'll remember
rioters chanted hang Mike Pence at the
Capitol after the former president lied
to support us about Pence's ability to
stop the certification of the election I
obviously have nothing to hide an
advisor to former vice president Mike
Penn says he could testify before the
D.C Federal grand jury within weeks and
I think the American people deserve the
whole story possibly providing a vivid
first-hand account of then president
Donald Trump's attempts to stay in
office fans could reveal details about
his Oval Office meetings with Trump just
days before January 6 and if the
pressure plan that involved tossing out
electors could amount to a criminal
conspiracy to overturn the 2020 election